I did mushrooms yeah which was quite
very helpful for me actually I mean I I
go into a really bad depression when I
take mushrooms because
um I think I'm allergic to them or
something I just just kind of I go get
really depressed for a couple days
um afterwards or not during afterwards
yeah no during is amazing I love I love
them but I've only done them a few times
but every time I've done them
something's changed in my life like
majorly changed
um I've either given up an addiction
or I've
you know for example I I came off
Twitter uh or stopped even stop kind of
really using it took mushrooms one day
uh we were sort of on a like a road trip
and uh we were sitting by a pool
and
I think this was the first time I
actually ever did them
was during the pandemic
um
and
I remember saying to my friend I'm not
really sure these are doing anything
um yeah totally sneak you right and then
he goes well you've you've been taking a
photo you've been taking photographs of
that same flower for the last two hours
and I noticed it and I look down at my
phone and there was like 400 I was like
scrolling through this 400 photographs
of this flower is really beautiful
flower but
um in hindsight probably
the mushrooms had something to do with
that
so um I so I just
look down at my phone
open Twitter and it just looked like a
Vortex oh yeah there was a very very
strange
like it was like fragmenting at the
edges you know like like an actual
Vortex
um and it looked like
extremely Dark Energy it's hard to
describe it
um
in sober wording but it was you know at
the time I would would have just kind of
felt this horrible
um kind of anxiety looking at it
and I just there and then deleted the
app
and just put the phone down and just go
on with my day and I didn't reinstall it
um
and there were a couple of other things
I did as well I did it with Instagram I
did it with like field because I just
noticed that the phone and actually the
phone itself was like just looked like
it was like charged with horrible like
nebulous like dark energy like felt like
a black hole basically yeah and it felt
like it was like drawing me towards it
but not in a good way like in a way that
um made me feel like I was dying so I
just thought no I'm that's telling me
something this is right you know I also
noticed the way my dog reacts on my
phone he
very often pours it away but also just
just won't engage with it he'll only
engage with me and if I'm engaging with
it then he'll he'll just kind of walk
off wow so it's almost like here's a
piece of Life telling you hey man that's
not life yes yeah that's what's very
well put that's what's interesting about
mushrooms man you'll give you a little
clue
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one